the first trailer for Sonic was released
a few days ago
however the fan community hasn't been
able to get much out of the trailer so
far despite Jim Carrey's appearance as
villain dr. Ivo Robotnik the biggest
flaw seems to be the appearance of the
protagonist Sonic since many fans just
want a comic like look on the poster
released at the beginning of the year as
well as in this trailer Sonic seems more
like a hairy blue human being or as
Twitter user Kyle Olson quite accurately
illustrates more like the monkey from
Jumanji and even though many fans are
positively surprised by Jim Carrey's
performance this won't make them want to
go to the Sonic movie shortly afterwards
however director Jeff Fowler responded
who surprisingly handled the criticism
very constructively and announced on
Twitter that the design of Sonic would
be changed again nobody expected that so
quickly but the high number of dislikes
and the devastating comments seemed to
have had an effect was a simple change
of the eye area seems to help a lot
how Sega and Paramount will make the new
Sonic look like we will surely see in
the next trailer Sonic the Hedgehog will
be released on November 8 2019 with
Disney hiring James Gunn a few weeks ago
for the third part of guardians of the
galaxy to surprise to many fans the only
downside was that the shooting could not
start until 2021 at the earliest with
the finish of The Suicide Squad however
now The Hollywood Reporter reckons to
know that the filming of the third part
would begin in 2020 one of the reasons
for this is that James Gunn had already
finished the script before he was kicked
out of Disney so that production could
begin more or less directly if this were
to happen early next year the end of
2021 would be a realistic release date
for guardians of the galaxy 3 provided
Gunn takes over his previous script
seamlessly and the production of The
Suicide Squad is not delayed after not
only James Caan as director but also
some actors like Margot Robbie Jai
Courtney and Viola Davis will return to
The Suicide Squad reboot it became known
a few days ago that David s mao-chan
better known as curtain ant-man will
also be part of the cast death mao-chan
will take over the role of ethnic R'lyeh
a polka-dot man which makes him one of
the smaller villains in the Suicide
Squad
however the dots on his costume can turn
into powerful flying weapons like
circular saws furthermore there are
currently conversations going on with
Daniela Meltzer who is a possible female
version of rat catcher the Suicide Squad
is scheduled to be released in mid 2021
after some pictures of the upcoming
Rambo 5 last Blood have been released
recently
so the Wester Stallone a brush the fans
personally from the set the clip
consists of behind the scenes shots and
shows the lone carving arrows and other
things he also promises that fans can
look forward to a handmade film like the
first part what exactly this means is
not sure however the first part goes
mostly without CGI fireworks the plot
will revolve around Gabriela the
daughter of John Rambo's housekeeper
because after she was kidnapped by a
Mexican woman trader cartel the retired
John Rambo decides that it has to take
care of the situation himself and save
Gabriela
you can also hope for a trailer soon
after all Rambo 5 last blood will be
released in the cinemas on September
20th 2019 after four published
videogames the Saints Row series will
now also be made into a film Saints Row
4 was the latest release for PC and
console in 2013 now several companies
have teamed up to produce a movie from
the popular series among them is the
German company coffe which not only owns
the rights to the video game series but
was also responsible for the latest
releases Saints Row 4 and Saints Row get
out of hell f Gary great who has already
been involved behind the scenes in
action movies like The Italian Job is
also supposed to be part of it in
addition grey is currently working for
men in black International and also had
a hand in Straight Outta Compton so he
doesn't have a lack of qualification
Greg Russo was hired as screenwriter and
has worked among others on Resident Evil
and Mortal Kombat so in fact they have
found some quite skilled people but
nevertheless many fans will be skeptical
about the filming of Saints Row after
all filmed video games have very often
disappointed the high expectations of
the fans the originally plans started
for fantastic beast 3 was supposed to be
November 2020 however it has now turned
out that fans of the Harry Potter
spin-off will have to wait longer
and this despite the big announcement of
Warner prior to the first part namely
that every two years from 2016 to 2020
for a new beasts movie will be released
however due to time difficulties the
release will be delayed by a whole year
a representative of Warner commented as
follows we are excited about the Beast
series and have complete faith in it we
believe that the new release date will
give the producers the time and space to
fully develop their art and deliver the
best possible film to our fans
this means the shooting will be delayed
and instead of starting in july 2019
there will not begin until spring 2020
whether the wait will at least have been
worth will be seen in november 2021 when
fantastic ps3 will start in the cinemas
[Music]